[Musique]
la Saint Firmin c'est pour les habitants
de Pampelune 8 jours de folie collective
la grande vedette de cette fête
interminable c'est le taureau c'est lui
qui fait naître l'hystérie chez tous
ceux qui rêvent de la gloire des arènes
et la peur panique chez les autres
[Musique]
sur la Plaza c'est là que grouille tous
les matador du dimanche 13 à toutes les
folies pour approcher le taureau
[Applaudissements]
dans cette foule des chenilles le
taureau lui ne sait plus où donner de la
corne il n'empêche qu'il restera le roi
de la reine jusqu'à l'heure de la
corrida
[Musique]
un miracle cette année il n'y a pas eu
de mort et pourtant les apprentis
toreros n'ont rien fait pour éviter le
pire
Christine Caron kiki pour les intimes
l'enfant prodige de la natation
française est un véritable petit poisson
remarquez bien qu'il lui arrive quand
même de sortir de l'eau de temps en
temps quand elle n'est pas dans une
piscine elle écoute Richard Anthony ou
bien elle dévore car elle a un appétit
d'ogre elle suit aussi des cours au
lycée mais là elle est beaucoup moins de
lui mais revenons à Kiki petit poisson
c'est sous la direction de son
entraîneur Suzanne berliou quel parcourt
ainsi 1000 km mes parents à Lana
on nage sur le dos c'est sa spécialité
Christine Caron s'est offert de
nouvelles journées de gloire à
l'occasion des championnats de France au
stade Georges Vallerey à Paris
les grandes n'ont pas pu lui résister et
Kiki le bébé nageur qui vient à peine
d'avoir 15 ans a remporté en quelques
gracieux battements le titre du 100
mètres et du 200 mètres d'eau
[Musique]
à Moscou c'est un temps de bonne humeur
qui a accueilli les délégués
britanniques et américains lors d'un
Cham et Monsieur Havré la riman à la
conférence des trois sur l'arrêt des
expériences nucléaires et thèse dès le
début la manifestation d'une volonté
générale d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
étant Turquie que son premier voyage
officiel à l'étranger a conduit le
Premier ministre monsieur Pompidou avec
pour compagnon un jeune étudiants sans
moyens qui rêvait de faire là-bas un
voyage d'études tous deux le Premier
ministre et l'étudiant ont pu en
survolant Istanbul et piloguer sur la
Vieille Capitale battue des eaux tièdes
du Bosphore ou du pont de Galatas à la
tour de Léandre s'est déroulée au long
de 1500 ans une partie de l'histoire du
monde
c'est un boule n'est plus
[Musique]
capable oublier qu'elle fut bizarre et
qu'elle fut Constantinople elle garde
avec ses dômes et ses minarets avec le
grouillement de la Corne d'Or avec la
couronne écroulée des remparts qui
résistèrent à combien d'assaut cette
revanche de demeurer l'une des villes du
monde les plus fabuleuses et les plus
poignants
[Musique]
elle reste faisant ornement des canons
qui bâtir ses murs miraculeusement
légendaire dans le décor des mille et
une nuits dressées par ses mosquées dont
certaines furent des églises et
l'idole de son bazar où l'on trouve tout
car ces réalités concrètes n'ont rien
aux rêves de cette ville unique où s'est
endormi tour à tour la puissance de
l'empire romain la gloire de Byzance et
la force de l'État haussement lit qui
devint avant 1914 l'homme malade de
l'Europe
c'est sur une autre Turquie qui a
débarqué monsieur George Pompidou le
chef du gouvernement turc monsieur
ismetinonu l'a accueilli à Ankara qui a
succédé comme capitale à Constantinople
et où le président de la République le
Général gursell devait entamer avec lui
un large tour d'horizon sur l'avenir
franco-turc
[Musique]
un Clara de l'imagination créatrice
digne et ses avenues ou les automobiles
croisent des attelages d'un autre temps
étaient tirés du néant il fut un effort
pour le concevoir la volonté de Kemal
Atatürk produisit ce miracle elle
enfitte un autre tirèrent un peuple
moderne d'une population illettrée
s'attaquant d'abord à l'esprit à ta turc
remplaça l'écriture sous-fite par
l'écriture romaine de ce fait la langue
turque a fait de nombreux emprunts
phonétiquement on s'y retrouve mais on
avait surprises
[Musique]
il n'en n'est pas moins que l'appétit du
savoir a conquis la Turquie l'école
compte parmi les grandes batailles qu'a
livrées et gagner le nouvel état dans
les villages les classes enfantines
dessinent dans l'air pour mieux les
apprendre les lettres de l'alphabet
et à l'université d'un carat des
fonctionnaires des commerçants des
employés suivent le soir les classes de
français que cherche-t-il ces adultes
dont la moitié au moins son chef de
famille le guide le plus sûr dans la vie
c'est la science leur a répondu à
[Applaudissements]
cette Turquie a dans le monde son rôle à
jouer son importance tient à ce poste
dangereux qu'elle occupe à la limite des
deux mondes gardienne des détroits elle
assure la permanence d'un équilibre
construit par cinq siècles de vie
européenne sentinelle du monde libre
elle monte la garde sur les flancs
glacés du Caucase comme aux lisière des
Balkans c'est 600 000 soldats instruits
et armés par l'Occident compost une
armée que les experts tiennent pour
l'une des forces les plus authentiques
de l'OTAN
ami depuis le 16e siècle partenaire
aujourd'hui au sein de l'OTAN demain au
sein du marché commun la France et la
Turquie se rapprochent à nouveau
aujourd'hui
c'est sans doute ce qu'a voulu
manifester monsieur Pompidou par sa
visite au pays data turc et par le geste
dommage qu'il a fait à la tête de la
délégation française au pied du
monumental tombeau ou repose tout près
de son rêve réalisé l'homme génial qui
est le seul lien ici entre le passé et
le présent
pour ces voyageurs décidés mais à la
Bourse plate que sont les auto-stoppeurs
la saison en France se révèle difficile
la presse a évoqué de sombres histoires
de malheureuses perspectives bref
l'autostop n'a plus la cote on a cité le
cas d'automobiliste serviable si l'on
peut dire jusqu'au bout des ondes et
l'excès en tout est un défaut
nul ne sait après tout ou commence la
route de Buenos Aires
on a cité aussi le cas de braves
autostoppeur dont les bagages ont été
complaisamment prise en charge et qui ne
les ont jamais revu
on a cité enfin le cas d'auto-stoppeur à
la main trop l'est pour qui l'auto-stop
n'était que la Libye de sombre projet
pour tout dire la méfiance règne et la
concurrence n'en est que plus redoutable
pour ceux qui restent en dépit de tout
fidèle à l'autostop l'organisation la
plus classique qui fait appel à des
techniques éprouvées reste encore
payantes il faut bien le dire
[Musique]
mais l'auto-stoppeur mâle si les isolés
ne devra-t-il pas désormais faire appel
à toutes les ressources d'une garde-robe
très étudiée les statistiques attestent
qu'une automobile s'arrête plus
facilement devant une jupe mais elle ne
parle que de la jupe
reste la soutane du prêtre qui demeure
avec l'abîme militaire une valeur sûre
de l'auto-stop
[Musique]
à ce point de raffinement autant adopter
la tenue de gendarme l'arrêt est
garantie
[Musique]
et l'automobiliste se sent même tout
naturellement porté à la prévenance
reste encore à savoir où tout cela vous
conduira
[Musique]